hey aloha and welcome to another
analysis
so uh today we have hikari nakamura
against maksim bashir lagrave
and uh it is the second day of the
quarterfinals
the story to the this game is also quite
funny because nakamura thought that he
was eliminated
after he lost yesterday to legrove he
lost the match
but it turned out he hadn't read the
regulations and that he has
a second chance to strike back
and to win technically win the match
if he manages to beat lagrave they
the games will turn into tie breaks so
um so he does have a second chance
must be a good feeling you know to
to realize that or to learn that you
have a second chance when you
cycle psychologically think that you're
out
so uh that that clip cracked me up
but uh without further ado let's take a
look here at uh nakamura and stomach
seems so e4
c5 knight f3 d6 you may recognize this
d4 takes takes knight f6 knight c3 and
a6
so this is the second time we take a
look at najdorf
together the other time was against
napogniachi
i can mention that maksim is more of a
hardcore
nidorf specialist he uh
he ha he is the absolute expert like
you don't get better than maxime and in
neither
that's uh that's the way i'll put it so
it's not a shocker that it plays
a6 i can mention that he
did play knight c6 in the qualification
stage
much to my surprise but anyway a6 and
nakamura once again chooses bishop d3 so
maybe bishop d3 is not converse pet line
so la gaurav goes for the same thing as
a nepo did with e5
not e2 knight c6 from
legrove fairly logical developing at the
knight
the knight could also go to d7 but if
you're gonna go to d7 you want to play
they should be six first because if you
go to d7 now
the bishop cannot go to e6 so 92 knight
c6
castles bishop e6 and again the same
plan from
nakamura like in the the pomonachi game
he wants to play f very quickly
and eventually knight d5 to avoid
d5 from the black side and
here lagrange makes a very interesting
choice
but as a matter of fact
it's a very bad move and that is a
logical d5 move here
and maybe very bad is an exaggeration
but this makes things a lot harder
for the frenchman as we are gonna see
soon a better move would be to simply
play the should be seven and wait with
d5 uh it's a bit too premature
although uh in neither it said that if
you play
e5 and you get to play d5 as well you're
doing very well but
it turns out the d5 is just not very
good here
nakamura goes for bishop g5 pinning the
knight on f6
and the d5 pawn is officially under
attack so black needs to make a choice
whether or not he's going to play d4 or
take on e4 personally i think that d
takes d4 is what makes the most sense
and that's indeed what uh
makarov does but if you would have
played d4 the simple bishop
knight d5 here would have been very good
and
one of the points here is that h5 could
come and then
black is pretty much overloaded so let's
say that we take on d5
e takes queen takes bishop to xf6
pawn takes f6 and then bishop e4 this
position here is
uh winning for white according to the
computers
and it is basically winning because of
the
amazing white square control of the
white bishop also knight f5 could come
queen f3 and
black has severe problems especially
with his
uh his king so i think d takes c4 is
better and that is what like craft does
not take c4 bishop b7 and one of the
major
issues here is that after bishop takes
f6 it's not good to take with the bishop
and the reason is that knight h5 is the
move that destroys everything for black
black cannot move the bishop because the
pawn of g7 will be hanging
which means that white is probably going
to take on f7
next or play queen f3 first
which is uh not very good even knight c5
could come in a few lines too
so this is very promising so gtex f6 is
more or less first
queen h5 from nakamura an important move
because you do not want to let
black play f5 that is quite important to
prevent
so that is why nakamura plays queen h5
queen g7
queen h6 well i did just say that he
he wants to prevent f5 but f5 doesn't
work
because we can simply play knight f6 now
and this would be
far too dangerous for example e4 oh the
rook is hanging
never mind then there's nothing to look
at because they're attacking the rook
and the pawn and f5
so castles is the logical choice and
nakamura has won a
pawn on f6 so legrove loses a pawn
it's not looking too good but he does
have
some compensation i mean the bishop pair
is always strong here
so maybe something like king b8 is not
too shabby
and hope that you have enough with
bishop f8
or whatever but queen b6 potentially
black is is struggling but
it's not over yet uh lagra plays knight
d4
rook t1 is a logical move should takes
a2
and while you always wonder if it works
but in this case uh i think b3 here is
i can't really see what you're going to
do
in order to prevent roof k1 and rook
takes a2 how do you prevent that
something like um king b8
and after rook a1 you can simply take
here
yeah that is uh that is a problem
because now you no longer have
the pin after rook c1 so that is the
point of king b8
but a better move would be than to
simply
play knight f5 or something and a
position like this would be
very good because rook a1 is coming next
huh very clever
but nakamura plays knight f5 bishop e6
knight xc7 queen takes e7
and well the material is equal but this
is very good for
for bl for whites because of the fact
that pawn on e5 is very weak the king is
quite weak
and c3 is going to come chase away the
knight and then bishop e4
could come white just has excellent
control
of the center and the different squares
rookie one attacking the pawn
and all of a sudden it takes an h7 which
slightly strange but it's very simple
there's nothing black you can do in
order to win back the pawn
queen b4 b3 king b8
queen g5 it's looking pretty bad now for
uh for maxime
he needs to watch out for just this
h-pawn just running down the board it's
very hard to to prevent to i can play
bishop to e3 and h5h
h4 h5 h6 h7 and i can do it without
any problems because i protect all of my
weaknesses and black has nothing
so for example rook d4 bishop b4
rook d8 now i want to avoid the trade of
rooks i'm just going to play rxe1 even
threatening c3
queen c3 and boom h4 and i'm going to
play h5
h6 h7 and there is nothing you can do in
order to stop me
so lagrav tries king h8 but then h5
rook d2 and after bishop d3 he actually
resides
and it's not surprising because 94 is
gonna come
and the rook on d2 is going to fall
but uh he didn't really have any moves
here
for example rook h8 is always met by for
example
h6 and h7 will come next
and it's uh it's over queen g7 too
just look at how well white's pieces are
placed they're just excellently placed
and the black has no moves
a beautiful game by nakamura who
makes use of his second chance
whether or not it will be enough to win
the match remains to be seen
but at least he's back in in the game
and uh i can't wait to see what happens
next
in this exciting match